Meet Lobo.
“Who are you?”
“Oh, I’m sorry...my card.”
He's basically a mashup of Superman and Wolverine:
an immortal, unkillable alien antihero that
happens to have super senses, a crazy healing
factor, and a love for beer and cigars.
Sounds great, right?
Well, not so much.
His biggest fans have waited years for Lobo
to make the jump to the silver screen — and
the success of 2016's R-rated Deadpool seemed
to be proof that bawdier comic book characters
would start heading to theaters in short order.
But, really, chances are pretty good that
it just won't happen.
“Mmm, I love you too.”
Here's why DC and Warner Bros. will never
give Lobo his own movie.
Parody problems
The most fundamental problem with creating
a Lobo movie is that Lobo is, at heart, a
parody.
The character was first created by writer/artist
Keith Giffen.
When asked why Lobo became so popular, Giffen
answered,
"I have no idea why Lobo took off.
I came up with him as an indictment of the
Punisher, Wolverine, bad ass hero prototype
and somehow he caught on as the high violence
poster boy.
Go figure."
But even though he started as a parody, Lobo's
biggest fans didn't really get the joke.
Or if they did, they didn't really care.
Lobo became a legitimate fan favorite.
But while Wolverine and the Punisher have
become iconic hits in both comics and on-screen,
an accurate adaptation of Lobo today would
just come across as a cheap rip-off of Marvel's
characters because…well…he kind of is.
As Giffen said, that was the whole point.
Too misogynistic
One of Lobo's signature character traits has
been his sexism and misogyny.
In one notable comic, he ripped the top off
of superheroine Starfire against her will
as "payment" for his help.
Now, if Lobo's nothing more than a parody,
this kind of thing is at least a little okay.
His awfulness and boundary pushing is the
joke, right?
But it's difficult to imagine that level of
casual sexism taking place in the same cinematic
universe as Lois Lane and the new, butt-kicking
Wonder Woman.
“You pig!
Ow!”
“Ahh!
I like a babe who plays rough.”
If nothing else, Lobo is a PR nightmare waiting
to happen.
That whole genocide thing
In most superhero stories, the hero is partially
defined by tragedy.
That goes for Batman losing his parents, or
Superman losing his entire planet.
These events shape their entire moral compass
and charts their course towards eventually
putting on a cape.
Lobo is literally the complete opposite: like
Superman, he's the last of his race.
Unlike Superman, he didn't lose his home planet
in a moment of tragedy.
Instead, he unleashed a plague that killed
his entire planet.
"I'm the last Czarnian.
I fragged the rest of the planet for my high
school science project.
Gave myself an A."
While we may cheer as Deadpool slices and
dices henchman, we know his victims are actually
bad guys who contributed to a mutant trafficking
ring.
Killing an entire planet, on the other hand,
is pretty over the top for most villains,
let alone goofy antiheroes.
Inconsistent power level
One of the basic rules of storytelling is
that characters must somehow be vulnerable.
This helps them face various crises and grow
over the course of a story.
When superheroes have no apparent vulnerabilities,
you have to introduce something.
That's one of the reasons why Superman's weakness
is Kryptonite: to bring him down to Earth.
Lobo's powers are inconsistent at best, and
ridiculous at worst.
He's literally unkillable, surviving everything
from the vacuum of space to the literal fires
of Hell.
Lobo can effortlessly go toe-to-toe with Superman
in a fight, and at one point he even gained
the ability to make clones of himself from
a single drop of blood.
How do you make a movie about an all-powerful
jerk who wears leather and rides a space motorcycle?
Oh, yeah—Lobo rides a space motorcycle.
Design throwback
Lobo faces a unique problem when it comes
to modern appearances.
The character was introduced in the 1980s,
and very quickly settled on his signature
look: a leather-clad space biker.
On Lobo's best day, he looks like an extra
from the original Mad Max movies.
And on his worst?
“At first I was scared ‘cause they looked
a little rough.
I thought they were gonna beat me up.
But they took me in their arms and told me
that I was a Bear too.”
“How are ya?”
And that might be problematic for the DC Extended
Universe as Warner Bros. tries to update the
look of its heroes and villains.
Don't ever change
So, with all these issues — from a nutty
origin, to crazy powers, to dated fashion
choices — why not just change him?
Well, DC tried that already, too.
When the publisher was busy reinventing its
heroes with visual and narrative revisions
in the "New 52" event back in 2011, Lobo got
a makeover of his own.
The result was a generic genre character,
who turned out to be the opposite of everything
Lobo's fans actually loved.
The outcry against the redesign was intense,
resulting in petitions, angry letters, and
really angry internet comments from Lobo's
fans.
If Warner Bros. sticks with the classic Lobo,
the movie is pretty much unmakeable.
If they change him, Lobo fans will go berserk.
Might as well not bother, right?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too.